on n'agit pas manger très très bien les
maisons hantées
à la nuit tombée l'idée même de visiter
une maison hantée peu glacé le sang ou
plus téméraires
surtout quand on apprend que dans
certains cas les maisons hantées ça se
ressent physiquement comme dans les
meilleures scènes de films d'épouvanté
il arrive ainsi aux habitants de
ressentir des sensations étranges quand
je suis étendu dans ce lit partiellement
ça me brûle sam enveloppes sur le lit
comme quelque chose de la voltage je
sais pas moi c'était terrible surtout
quand l'esprit se sert d'objet de la
pièce pour les projeter sur quelqu'un
alors c'est la blessure
vous êtes très mignon ce qui m'a plu
chez les maisons hantées
ça peut donc faire mal même si on a
toujours du mal à y croire quand même
comme on l'a vu pour dire une farce aux
morts mais pour certains tout est
possible possible tout est possible
faudra pas sur la lune et pouvoir des
cobayes aux gens à prendre l eau
[Musique]